so now that i've had some time to step
away from its campaign and look at it
from different angles more critically i
can say with full confidence that i
thoroughly enjoyed halo infinite story
it's easily the best one 343 has ever
made and while it's not without its
faults it's still a wonderful story
regardless so today i want to take some
time to discuss my thoughts on the game
and how i felt while playing it of
course spoiler warning ahead as i'll be
talking about the entire story in length
but with that out of the way let's get
started before we get into the video
though we do have a message from our
sponsor rage shadow legends you've heard
it before and you've probably already
played it before but this time is a
little different it's still the same
fantastic game we all know and love that
gives you access to over 600 different
champions that's available on mobile and
pc but red shadow legends has added its
newest clan boss the hydra to its game
it's got six heads all with different
mechanics and abilities making it one of
the strongest clan bosses to date i've
decided to finally give the game a try
and i must say the highlights of this
game have to be its pace and
accessibility i've always preferred to
play my games slow and to play them
alone which is why i'm so infatuated
with story games raid shadow legends
allows you to play your own pace and is
very solo friendly allowing you to do
most of the content in the game by
yourself if that hasn't already piqued
your interest there's also the free
champion modeled after cs go pro simple
available now until january 28th for
both old and new players of the game
just looking at its new content there
isn't a better time to start playing
click the link in the description or
scan the qr code on screen to get the
epic champion rector draith 200 000
silver one energy refill one xp boost
and one ancient shard these are only
going to be available for the next 30
days so you have to hurry once redeemed
all items will be sent to your inbox and
game located here as always make sure to
check out raid shadow legends in the
description down below and thank you to
them for sponsoring this video now let's
get back to the content so hello
infinite decided to take a new approach
to its story we're introduced to a new
faction called the banished they were
originally in halo wars 2 so fans of
that game will already know of their
existence but for those who enjoyed the
fps side of the franchise 343 cater to
them as well by truly showing how
powerful they are there are many times
throughout the franchise like when
sergeant johnson or captain keys were
captured in the original trilogy that
you would think well if the master chief
was there none of this would have
happened with the banished however
things are different not only does the
banish completely wipe out the unsc
infinity in minutes but the master chief
is on board to take it a step further he
actually lost to my knowledge this is
the one and only time he's actually lost
within the games the only part in the
series that was this close was the
didact introduction where chief was
overpowered almost immediately but the
didact just threw the chief and left
atriox wasn't playing around he
pulverized the chief i've never seen him
get tossed around this much before it
wasn't just a loss it was an
overwhelming loss the only hits the
chief got in during this fight were
these couple punches in the middle to
which he received a hammer right on the
top of the skull because of it even with
the strength of the mjolnir armor he
wasn't able to get up right away and
defeat him it is such a wonderful
introduction to halo infinite does it
really portrays how deadly the banished
are this cutscene also brings up another
change in that it's all the cutscenes as
a whole hill has never been new to
action movie style cinematics that are
easily able to convey an emotion without
saying a word but while 343 does this
from time to time i found there not to
be as many action scenes this time
around only a handful of them were
actually wide shots as most of them were
all really up close this conveyed to me
that we were not experiencing an action
movie but more a somber deeply personal
story and that's what infinite is really
about yes there was a lot of action and
the threat of humanity being at stake is
still very relevant again but it never
felt like that plot was at center stage
more of just something to break up the
actual story of infinite which was
chief's relationship with cortana the
weapon and the pilot despite the chief
constantly saying that cortana needs to
be deleted and trying to back up his
statements by referencing all the past
atrocities she committed we all know the
chief did not want to do that even
during the game we hear him mention how
everything that happened was his fault
and how he wished he could have reasoned
with her except we know that cortana was
never going to leave her position of
power due to their conversation in halo
5. as she went as far as trapping blue
team into kryptum so that they couldn't
interfere with her work she never wanted
to kill them as they are family to her
but she also didn't want them to ruin
her plans however while initially he
feels remorseful he starts to evolve
over the course of the campaign and
learned to accept his fate and also
learn to accept those he's grown close
to both the pilot and the weapon do like
the chief there is no doubt about that
but chief's actions throughout the game
soured their relationships quite a bit
the pilot rescued the chief back in the
beginning of the game and was super
excited to find him not because he was
going to help wipe out the banish but
that's so he could have a safe escort
home we discovered that the pilot wasn't
actually a pilot or a marine he stole
the pelican that he pilots he explains
that he was scared and that he didn't
want to die so he stole the pelican and
has been hiding in it for months when we
make it to zeta halo the pilot thinks
the chief is going there to retrieve a
physical weapon that he can use to
defeat the banished as they try to
escape but the master chief has other
plans as he has no intention of actually
leaving zeta halo until the banished are
gone the chief never lets the pilot know
this and is being dragged along thinking
that after this he'll go home like okay
the chief is here we can go home oh wait
he wants a weapon alright well after the
weapon then we can go home oh the
banister trying to rebuild these spires
to repair the ring okay i get that but
after that then we can go home it's not
until they crash land when the pilot
finally blows up on him about it his
mood does slightly change as he
discovers numerous frigates nearby that
may have slip space drives that they can
use but the master chief says his
mission is more important but after it's
done they'll go search for one except
it's too late as when he gets back from
his mission all the frigates were
scrapped and the tech was destroyed he
once again blows up on the chief and
starts throwing all the debris around as
all he wants to do is go home he doesn't
care about this war anymore as humanity
has already lost he just wants to go
home and not be caught in the crossfire
the chief then sits down next to him and
explained that everyone makes mistakes
and that making mistakes is what means
to be human to the pilot the chief may
as well be a divine being there's no way
a mere human can stop the covenant army
and annihilate the flood it has to be
the work of a god but the master chief
really is just a human and 343 has
started taking the chief down this path
of realism and it's one that bungie
never really touched on before master
chief in the original trilogy had very
little faults and was a master of combat
everything he did was calculated and
precise like when he launched the bomb
at the covenant carrier in halo 2 or
jumped off that 4runner ship in halo 3
but 343 wanted to humanize the chief
more by showing his faults and failures
and it's these exact traits that change
the pilot as he realizes that even
humanity's greatest soldier can fail and
he also starts to recognize the role he
plays on this team he may not have
wanted this role in the team but it's
clear what he did is help the chief
whether it's giving him gear and weapons
from the fobs or more obviously rescuing
him in the intro despite how useless he
feels in comparison to the chief in the
weapon he is just as important as a role
as the others do and it's that
realization that he isn't worthless and
does matter that changes him he's now
more willing to help the chief with his
mission and understands the importance
of his role in that mission the same
evolution occurs in the weapon she was
originally just any other ai she had one
purpose in life and once that purpose
was fulfilled she would be deleted but
the master chief knows more about her
than even the player knows at this point
it's not just a coincidence that she
looks and sounds like cortana as we
discover that she literally is cortana
just without all the memories she and
chief had throughout their journey at
the beginning of the game the weapon
just seems like a separate ai but from
her mission to her mannerisms we get
hints that this is not true her original
mission was to imitate cortana in hopes
of luring her to zeta halo where she
would be trapped i find it quite hard
for the unsc and dr halsey to create an
ai that is able to imitate cortana
without that ai not being her in some
way it just doesn't seem feasible to me
this was a hint towards the weapon being
related to cortana in some way but i
never expected her to be a literal copy
the reveal of this was great as they
showed how even their mannerisms were
the same as they both snapped their
fingers now i tried to look through all
my footage of the halo games which is
easily over 20 hours of footage so it
would take a lot of time to actually
sift through it all but i don't recall
cortana ever actually snapping her
fingers even in the 343 games i don't
remember her doing this i feel like this
was something that was just added into
halo infinite as a way to show how the
weapon and cortana are the same going
back to the weapon she is master chief's
new ai and new ally she obviously cares
about him and wants to help him but
despite all her efforts he still doesn't
trust her when the two are working
together to take down the spires we see
that the weapon is being scanned by
something we don't know what however
that's not a good sign master chief then
prepares this deactivation program so
that he can delete the weapon he's going
to outright delete her at the first sign
of trouble despite cortana being stuck
on high charity with the gravemind and
actively trying to harm him throughout
halo 4 and 5 whether intentional or not
he always refused to delete her and
wants to fix her because the chief cares
about her but because the only person he
truly cares about is gone now he stopped
caring about those around him both the
pilot and weapon were just seen as
things he can use the weapon after this
becomes rightfully upset with him as she
learns that he tried to delete her the
two end up getting into an argument
about it and he tries to convince her
that he was trying to stop her from
putting the mission at risk but once
again cortana has been in worse
situations and he never thought of
deleting her despite all of this she
still continues to work with him as she
understands that the mission is very
important and it's not worth
compromising the mission over their
relationship during their down time when
things aren't going on is when she finds
it appropriate to bring it back up again
their one engagement shortly after this
was also a hint towards cortana and the
weapon being one in the same as when
they argue he says cortana's name i
trusted you why can't you do the same
you don't understand try me cortana
judging from the pause in between his
sentence it seems that since the weapon
and cortana are the same he got them
mixed up and ended up saying her name
instead i'm not entirely sure if the
player was supposed to interpret it this
way but that's what i got from it and it
makes the showcase of their relationship
and the build-up to that reveal much
better as i said earlier the weapon and
the pilot are just things he can use in
his mission this also relates to their
names they are things not actual names
he also never calls them the weapon or
the pilot we the player just call them
that it's on until the end of the game
where he finally learns both their names
which is showing how the master chief is
thinking of them as real people not just
a role in his mission the weapon isn't
just a weapon used to destroy the
banished and the pilot isn't just a
pilot taking him to places he needs to
go they're real people to him and people
he cares about and wants to protect in
the beginning the relationship felt
forced and shaky between the three but
by the end they feel like a well-oiled
machine each serving a role on the team
and realizing that despite each of their
faults they're just as equally important
as the other and this goes back to what
i was talking about earlier how 343 is
trying to humanize the chief now they're
keeping with the theme of him being an
unstoppable force but they're showing
his flaws and mistakes and it's these
mistakes that inspire those around him
it's some fantastic storytelling and a
wonderful experience to see unfold
however this is just one part of the
overall story the other side of the
story is with the banished and right out
of the gate to the banister a fantastic
faction i've always been a fan of the
covenant but the prometheans just worked
my cup of tea because it felt too sci-fi
for halo i know how crazy that sounds
given the technology of this game but i
don't mind the alien looking species
like the covenant or even the harbinger
but the mechanical nature of the
prometheans just never sat right with me
like i said i understand how potentially
hypocritical that may sound but that's
just my opinion regardless the banished
seem to scratch my itch perfectly as
they closely resemble the covenant but
aren't an actual copy it allows the
enemies in combat to feel familiar but
also feel new at the same time but the
banister aren't great just from a
gameplay perspective but also from a
story one as well they feel strong and
we get to see that right in the opening
minutes it makes the story all the more
engaging as it's not a story of the
master chief defeating the covenant for
the millionaire's time him losing
signifies that these enemies are
stronger than we think and that things
can go wrong and we might end up getting
the bad ending by the time we reach the
epilogue as for the characters
themselves the three main pillars of the
faction being atriox escherim and jega
are all fantastic i was really upset
that they killed jewel mandama off right
away in halo 5 as i felt like there
wasn't enough time spent with him even
though we did get to see him quite
substantially in spartan ops with these
three i was eagerly waiting for them to
show up even when ashram said that
atriox was dead i wasn't bothered by
this as i was with joule mujul mendama
dead there really wasn't much point to
the covenant existing anymore and the
game sort of knew this as they did away
with the covenant for most of the game
and really tried to focus on the
prometheans and cortana but with halo
infinite atriox being dead means nothing
as jega and ashram still exist and will
take his place we don't hear about a
successor to jewel's role as supreme
commanders you could stop caring about
the covenant altogether and it makes it
feel like they already lost but with
atriax dead it still feels like the
banish have the upper hand despite
losing their warmaster this was a much
better way of killing a character early
in the game without ruining the
integrity of the story now obviously
this is made even better when we
discover atriox isn't actually dead but
we'll get to that later voltage and
escheron both have roles and
personalities that are only distinct
from one another but it's these exact
qualities that make them likable
antagonists i couldn't wait to finally
fight jega as he was such an anomaly
within this faction and i couldn't wait
to see what would happen when we
actually did meet him these cutscenes we
see from them also bring up another
point i've been meaning to mention but
it's that this game is gorgeous i've
always liked the sort of realistic
graphics of halo 3 in reach but just
like the prometheans the hyper realism
of halo 4 and 5 just felt too much to me
master chief's armor just had too much
detail going on but infinite nails the
perfect blend of this i've seen a lot of
complaints about this game downgrading
its graphics but in this case it
actually makes the game better this also
extends to the banished as their visual
design is fantastic and with a change in
their color palette it allows them to
further separate from the covenant
making them feel new going back to the
banished i think both jega and ashram
are standout characters within the game
as while they just want to kill the
master chief the characters themselves
are different than that ashram
constantly wants to challenge the chief
and he is eagerly waiting for the time
they stand in front of one another the
jega the master chief is just another
spartan he's killed tons before so how
is this any different jega's boss fight
is easily one of the best in the game as
the chief is tasked with going through
this arena of torture before being stuck
in a tiny room with two floors no lights
and barely any cover to top it off jega
has active camo and two energy swords
not only does he look cool but this
fight is nerve-racking thanks to the
huge buff that activecamo got in halo
infinite it is so hard to see where an
enemy is unless you're standing still
this leaves you exposed to the active
camo user making the fight even harder
plus the energy swords are just as
deadly as before it's a fantastic fight
and it gets even better once you get
introduced to ashram as he is kitted
with full armor and is ready to fight
even as a second phase where he chases
you with his gravity hammer i have never
felt more stressed in this game than i
have here and it's the story and their
personalities that made this enjoyable
jager being a spartan killer was huge
this could be the first time in a while
where we feel like the opponent we face
is on an even playing field with us and
with eshroom you could tell just from
his attitude that this was going to be a
very tough fight ashram loves the
feeling of battle so it makes sense how
he gets excited when we finally come
face to face with him there's no
gimmicks with him there's no cheap
tactics like with jega it's just a test
of metal as he puts it this is probably
why he made jega fight the chief first
as esheram holds jega to a very high
esteem so if the spartan can kill a
spartan killer then this will be a
battle for the ages this fight is what
esheram has been waiting for no one in
the unsc is as tough as the chief so if
ashram can defeat him he'll be a living
legend and praised forever i was so
engaged in these battles not because of
how tough they are but what they meant
which is why i felt it'd be poetic for
ashram to die by the weapon of his
friend the moment after his defeat was
also just wonderful even though he lost
he still won't stop until the chief
kills him or he becomes victorious the
chief also respects him during his death
which is something he hasn't done before
ashram and the chief are one and the
same just soldiers in a war hoping they
do the right thing and seeing as they're
on a leveled playing field in regards to
their skill he wanted to show him a sign
of respect it was honestly quite
touching and something i didn't expect
the chief to do considering how many
other covenant foes he's killed
throughout the franchise if it wasn't
obvious from how long i've discussed
these characters the banish the pilot
and the weapon are incredibly unique and
wonderful additions to this game the
chief was also given more human emotions
giving the chief the opportunity to
evolve as a character and even giving
others around him the chance to evolve
but these characters are just part of
the overall story as we still have yet
to talk about halo infinite's
overarching narrative halo infinite is
about the master chief learning to
accept his new fate and continuing to
work and care for those people around
him and it's because of cortana that
this happened he finally has to come to
terms with her death and accepts that he
can't change the past but he can change
the future he failed to stop cortana but
he won't fail his new friends that's
what caused him to reflect on his own
actions like his dismissive attitude
towards the pilot or how he just sees
the weapon as a weapon to fight the
banished what ties all these characters
and narrative evolutions together is
this ongoing plot with atriox cortana
and the harbinger we learn from the
echoes of cortana that she is to blame
for so many atrocities that have
occurred she's completely destroyed
sydney australia blew up laconia station
and erased the banished homeworld right
in front of atriox's eyes not only was
the reveal of these events really well
done i liked that it was able to
showcase the motivations behind atriox
as of the harbinger she's interesting to
say the least she's of a completely new
species so this is already captivating
enough as this could lead to more story
regarding her species which is most
likely where this game is gonna head but
the harbinger throughout the game will
continue to talk about the endless this
unknown faction or group that we the
player don't even know of yet her goal
is separate from the banished and i do
appreciate the detail of them working
together to achieve their goal but not
actually working together they don't
hate each other but they definitely
don't trust one another but they need to
in order to get their way it establishes
different motivations and different
personalities between the characters and
that it was just an overall great
addition to the game what did bother me
at least initially was how quickly she
fades out of the game's existence she's
introduced in the middle of the game and
is gone by the end however given her
name the harbinger i didn't feel that
way anymore as a harbinger is someone or
something that announces the approach of
something else her motivations and goals
are all based around the textbook
definition of her name after realizing
this i didn't feel as bad that she died
so soon as i became more interested in
what was to come after her death what
exactly that is remains unknown but
numerous theories have already been
started as the post-credit cutscene of
halo infinite shows us that atriox is
still alive but in a different point in
time he seems to have time traveled back
in time for some reason we also hear two
people speaking during the legendary
ending which is someone called the great
edict and then despondent pyre who we
already know of but more importantly
it's the fact that offensive bias is
being activated now i'll be the first to
admit most of my halo knowledge comes
from the games with only the smallest
amount of info being outside sources so
i knew who they were talking about but
someone who has never read the books
will not but i don't mind this halo
infinite really feels like a game for
those who have played the prior releases
it's quite the hard game to jump into as
a first-time halo player so this ending
was really for the fans the ones who
know who offensive bias is and what this
could mean for the future the main
question of course is how atriox went
back in time and it ties into the
harbinger and the endless who people
assumed to be the precursors once again
people who don't know what the
precursors are will be scratching their
head at these theories but halo infinite
is for the dedicated players it creates
some intrigue in new players as while
these names and factions can be a bit
overwhelming they're still very
interesting and it also creates
excitement in the veteran players as
they know the lore and are excited as
different pieces of the overall universe
are finally being put into the games
from start to finish this game was
incredible however i do have some issues
with the game but it's issues that can
be fixed my biggest issue and it's the
issue lots of people in my comments
section of my video were talking about
was cortana's death and the story's
length despite being an open world game
if you were to just play its story it's
just as long as any other halo game i
beat it on my first playthrough in about
6 hours obviously this is a weird thing
to critique but given that all the story
is within the main content and not open
world activities it's really just a
regularly sized halo game without the
feeling of completion once the credits
rolled the story's done and when they
did roll i felt like we were just
getting started we got introduced to the
harbinger the endless and atriox going
back in time yet it just ends this was
something the original game struggled
with especially with halo 2 as nothing
felt accomplished obviously with that
game that was more due to development
issues but still the players at the time
didn't know that halo 2 was going to get
a sequel and they thought this is all
they were left with this is the same for
halo infinite will halo infinite get a
sequel absolutely there is no doubt in
my mind that it will so there's going to
be some new story content except we
don't know when some people have stated
halo infinite is supposed to be a
10-year game assuming this is true then
we'll either have to wait 10 years for a
new story or wait until the dlc if there
even is dlc the problem is that neither
option is confirmed halo infinite might
be a 10-year game but maybe it's just
for multiplayer there's nothing stopping
them from shafting the single-player
fans and making them wait a decade for
new content the fact that the time frame
is that long though is what leads people
to believe that story dlc will be coming
out for this game which if that's the
case and this entire argument is
redundant i only feel this way about the
game's story because who knows how long
it'll be until the next installment but
if dlc is currently something 343 is
looking into then i'm all for it as this
story is really something and it needs
to be explored as soon as possible the
other criticism i've seen is about
cortana and how it was never shown to
the player how she managed to lose her
influence despite being incredibly
powerful and the fact that they killed
her off using a flashback while i agree
it's maybe not the greatest way to go
about it i think it's 343's attempt at
trying to push her away from us the way
that cortana is pushing the master chief
away from her so that he can focus on
the future is how 343 is treating us i
feel like this is what they always
wanted to do with cortana as this is
what occurred in halo 4. the problem is
that they wrote themselves into a corner
which led into halo 5 but after some
time they eventually regained their
footing and committed to it now that
they have the weapon the banished and
the endless to explore so i really don't
mind that she's dead and i also don't
mind how it was presented as it goes
back to what i said before cortana
doesn't want to meddle in the chief's
life anymore that was the whole point of
her message at the end of the game she
has this poison that the chief can't let
go of but now that she's officially dead
she thinks this will allow the chief to
stop looking at the past and move on in
this instance we are the chief cortana
is gone and we have to accept that and
the more they put her on screen the more
we start to care about her and less
about the characters within that new
game despite how incredible and iconic
she is we need to move on halo
infinite's campaign was fantastic and is
without a doubt the best game 343 has
ever made its story was well constructed
so that everything fit where it needed
to within the game's world and it was
intriguing enough that it made me want
to see what would come next halo
infinite is not the best game in the
series but given how halo 4 and 5 were
presented this was a huge breath of
fresh air for the franchise with that
being said though we have come to the
end of the video thank you for watching
and making it this far i really enjoyed
making this story review and it's
something i've been wanting to do for a
lot of other games for a while so be on
the lookout for that kind of content in
the future as always like the view if
you enjoyed and subscribe if you're new
if you want to see more halo content
like this i made a retrospective review
on the main entries in the series and i
also made a recap of halo infinite's
story in case things got confusing be on
the lookout for more content like this
in the near future for many other games
and of course thank you to my returning
viewers for coming back to another video
take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you